can you pull up the mark of the John
Hopkins article I just want to really
get uh Jordan's that article yeah so so
here's CNN MSNBC New York Times wapo
Washington Post completely avoid John
Hopkins study finding uh coveted
lockdown's ineffective FYI would you say
John Hopkins is a conservative
organization like Hoover Institute no or
Heritage no Johns Hopkins is one of the
most reliable medical scientific
research Enterprises universities in the
world Bar None that's very important for
people because it's extremely reliable
so it's not like it's a CNN this is
Harvard it's Oxford Cambridge level
Johns Hopkins especially in the medical
domain so watch this ABC CBS NBC also
ignored the anti-log lockdown study so
go up let me read this so here we go
there has been a full-on media block on
the study online and if ineffectiveness
of lockdowns to prevent covet debts
according to John Hopkins University men
Allah's analysis of several studies
lockdowns during first coveted wave in
Spring of 2020 only reduce Copic
mortality by point two percent that is
not a lot in U.S and in Europe while the
meta-analysis concludes that lockdowns
have had little to no public health
effects they have imposed enormous
economic and social costs where they
have been adopted the researcher wrote
in consequence lockdowns policies are
ill-founded and should be rejected as a
pandemic policy instrument if you can go
a little higher I want to read the next
two and I'll get Jordan thoughts however
the Johns Hopkins study received no
mention on any of the five liberal
networks this week according to uh
Arabian a transcripts CNN MSNBC ABC CBS
NBC all ignore the anti-lockdowns
findings after having spent much of the
pandemic shaming red states with minimal
restrictions and events deemed by
critics as super spreaders it wasn't
just the networks avoiding the study the
New York Times The Washington Post the
Associated Press Reuters USA Today axios
political amongst other outlets also
tuned a black a blind eye to the
findings according to search results
Jordan how important is this research
like how important is is this analysis
that we're reading here right now I
should tell you what a meta-analysis is
please begin with well imagine there's a
group of studies done on a particular
topic and you write a review and you try
to interpret the findings that
was called a narrative review you use
your opinion in some sense to Wade
through the data and try to understand
what the compilation of studies reveals
well there were techniques developed 25
years ago that are statistical where you
can aggregate the statistical results
from studies statistically so you do a
statistical analysis of all the
statistical analysis and now it's a
meta-analysis and hypothetically it's
more objective and there's some truth to
that claim you still have to select
which studies to include but I I don't
believe that that was a detriment in
this particular case and so solid
methodology
and it's basically something
approximating a cost-benefit analysis
and that has its that's tough too
because it's not that easy to assign
costs and benefits in a quantitative
manner having said all that it's well
it's an amazing study
not only because of what it reveals
which is a 0.2 percent decline in
overall mortality but also in that the
the researchers felt so strongly about
their findings that they
came right out and said that this was
ineffective policy and that isn't that
common for researchers who generally
hold off on drawing that sorts of
conclusions they kind of lay out the fat
of black and white they're typically not
going to come out as black and white is
what you're saying yes yes exactly
exactly and so so that's that's really
something we rushed to imitate a
totalitarian state in panic and the
consequence of that according to this
study was
there's zero there's nothing positive
about it now I've talked with some
Democrats about this study because they
were paying attention to it and their
response is something like
well
it did help control Hospital overrun
and time will tell whether or not that's
true I think the data suggesting that
covid vaccines decreased the seriousness
of illness when people contracted covid
who were vaccinated I think that data is
credible
I could be wrong about that because
things are being done in a rush and it's
very difficult to draw appropriate
scientific conclusions in a rush but I
think the bulk of the information
suggests that but I also think that is
not how they were marketed and that was
not the initial intent to merely reduce
severity of the illness it was to reduce
transmission and and so forth and and
then of course this is a cost-benefit
analysis which says yeah there was some
gain on that front conceivably Maybe
although all-cause mortality doesn't
seem to have gone down much at all but
the economic the secondary consequences
were devastating and well we don't even
know what the secondary consequences are
yet you know the here's one secondary
consequence
which is revealed in what you just read
the collusion of the press and the
government
like how do you know that's not worse
than the epidemic it could easily be
worse than the epidemic or the idea that
now
we've been
uh
coerced into
having to share our medical information
with people all through the bureaucratic
hierarchy all the way down to servers
and restaurants so we've trained people
that that's okay to ask and also to
offer
is that worse than the pandemic well
these are arguably
all of this involves violation of our
fundamental rights
where's the evidence that that's not
worse well we're going to see it play
out well the collusion between the press
and the government that's so intense in
Canada as already said when the premier
of ex-premier of Newfoundland wanted to
launch his constitutional challenge he
couldn't use a mainstream news source I
mean that's a bloody catastrophe much as
I dislike CBC which is a lot by the way
I think that it's an absolute
catastrophe that it's come to that and
that's just one of you know two
consequences of the lockdown there's the
supply chain problem that's a big one
you know I my publisher penguin told me
a week and a half ago we were talking
about putting out a two volume set of my
last two books which I would really like
to do they're going to do that and Great
Britain
I I think that people would
turn to it as a gift for graduations and
so on that would be a nice set for that
um they told me they can't get paper
this is penguin random house right and
it's paper
paper isn't that complex given how
complex everything is the fact that
there are paper shortages that's a big
deal I was in a Mazda dealership in
Canada a couple of be a couple of months
ago now
that one car
one isn't very many cars you know and
and so we have no idea what the supply
line crunch is going to produce in terms
of economic because seriously though and
then the next issue is
well how about all the money we've been
printing
you know we've already seen that produce
a massive bubble expansion in housing
prices that's being driven by other
factors how do we know that's not worse
than the pandemic you know it could
easily be I'm not saying that it is
because I don't know but that's the
issue I don't know and this is partly
why this mad rush to impose top-down
solutions to complex problems this is in
some sense what makes me a conservative
insofar as I am it's part of the caution
I learned as a social scientist so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]